on increasing use of drones here in the
u.s and abroad and how it all got
started with remarks from author richard
whittle the name of his book is predator
the secret origins of the drone
revolution
i'm thrilled to
welcome you here
this afternoon my name is wolfgang
porzik
and i serve for dhl as
executive vice president for corporate
public policy
the dhl group is a
global leader in express delivery
logistics
and supply chain management
yes
it is true that dhl
about a week ago
announced the following and i quote
from a press release
for the first time worldwide
medications and other urgently needed
goods
will be delivered to the island of juice
which is in the north sea
at certain times of the day
by dhl parcel copter
this research project represents the
first and only time in europe
that a flight by an unmanned aircraft
will be operated outside
of the pilot's field of vision in a real
life vision
by taking this step the agile parcel has
moved to the next phase of the
parcelcopter research project
it launched in 2013
end of quote
this innovative approach to deliver
parcels however
is not the reason for
today's booklet
dhl's operations are impacted
by
public policy decisions worldwide and
obviously in the us as well for better
or worse
dhl worldwide operates aircraft
runs large
truck fleets and employs ocean vessels
for transportation our business is
directly impacted by political
regulatory decisions and regimes that's
why we
engage in the
public discourse on
current
public policy
issues
the technology we will talk about today
has impacted
the
political environment
in a substantive substantive way who
knows what further
opportunities these technological
advances will produce
there may
well be applications for civilian use in
the transportation and logistics sector
that's why we as dhl are interested to
learn more
about richard whittle's research
equally important however is the fact
that richard and i have been close
personal friends
for a little more than 30 years we have
worked together
on a number of projects over these many
years and i'm
delighted
and it's a real privilege indeed for me
that i can welcome
our author richard whittle
and you
interested in his work product his most
recent
book on the development of drones
richard whittle is a global fellow at
the wilson center
and a research associate at the national
air and space museum where he finished
writing this book as a verbal fellow
during the academic year 1314.
most of you know that richard has
written about the military for more than
30 years including 22 as a pentagon
correspondent for the
dallas morning news
this book which came out just two weeks
ago or so
has
accumulated quite some accolades
from very different and very
authoritative
writers
and
media outlets
amazon selected the book as one of the
best 15 history books recently
the kirkus review gave it a coveted
start review reserved for books of
exceptional merit the wall street
journal called the book predator
fascinating
the washington post said that richard's
reporting in predator is methodical
incredible
no small feat given the lid of silence
that the air force the caa the obama
administration and general atomics have
welded onto their drone operations even
the trivial parts the post review added
that whittle's best material appears in
the final chapters when he delivers
action-packed details about how the cia
and the pentagon used armed predators to
hunt for al-qaeda leaders immediately
after 9 11 based on interviews with
numerous participants
ladies and gentlemen we are in for a
special treat
and richard
welcome the floor is yours
[Applause]
well uh thank you wolfgang for that uh
very nice introduction and
i think we also need to point out
besides the fact that it's coincidence
that dhl started this parcel copter
operation that
and and my book is about the predator
that your parcel copter is not armed so
far exactly right
anyway i'm very i'm very grateful to you
wolfgang for your for your hospitality
today and for your friendship
and uh thank you all for coming to hear
about my new book predator the secret
origins of the drone revolution
uh it's an honor to speak to such a
distinguished audience is this
especially when we have two former air
force leaders with us today former
secretary whit peters
and
retired lieutenant general jack rives
who was the judge advocate general of
the air force i'm i'm honored that
you're here today
i'm also honored that retired general
jack daly
is here for in addition to being
a former assistant commandant of the
marine corps
and a former deputy administrator of
nasa
general daly is director of the national
air and space museum
where i've been enjoying his hospitality
so to speak
since the fall of 2013 first as a
research fellow and now as a research
associate
thank you for being here general i
appreciate it
but let me add
that neither the air for the air and
space museum
nor general daily uh bear any
responsibility whatsoever for anything
in my book or anything that i'm going to
say today
they are innocent
uh it's also an honor to talk about
drones at an event hosted by dhl which
is wolfgang has just
explained is now doing what others have
been talking about
and
i hope that in addition to delivering
medicine that maybe someday you start
delivering books
my book tells what i thought was going
to be the story of an extraordinary
airplane
but turned out to be a story of
invention
a story of war
a story about the air force
and a story about the cia
and i believe the story of how a new age
in aviation began
five years ago i set out to write a book
about that new age in aviation and at
first i thought i would take a
comprehensive look
at unmanned
aerial systems or unmanned aerial
vehicles uavs as many experts like to
call them
but then
i read an article in air and space
smithsonian magazine
describing 10 aircraft that changed the
world
one of the 10 and the only uav was the
predator
and that brought things into focus for
me
the predator
was the uav that changed the world
and as i thought about what that meant
it seemed to me more and more evident
that the predator not only changed the
world of warfare
but opened the door to today's unmanned
civilian aviation revolution
and that was a story i immediately knew
i wanted to write the story of the
predator
and the origins of the drone revolution
and as i found out in the five years
writing this book took me
the story of this little drone that
changed the world is as strange as the
aircraft itself
and many of those who created this
revolutionary technology were just as
unorthodox as the predator
take the predator's inventor
abraham karam
a former israeli aeronautical engineer
many people regard as a genius
abe karim was born in baghdad in 1937
but he grew up amid the socialist
idealism that characterized israel in
the late 1940s and early 1950s
by his early 30s karim was director of
preliminary design and special projects
at israel aircraft industries
the country's most important
aerospace manufacturer
but abe grew frustrated by the corporate
climate and cynicism he saw at iai in
the early 1970s
and after working on a drone decoy
uh to fool arab air defenses in 1973
he was inspired to strike out on his own
and develop uavs
karim immigrated to the united states
the land of opportunity
and like all great american inventors he
went to work in his garage
his was in los angeles
now as a young man in israel abe had
been a free flight modeling champion
and the sports principles stuck with him
in free flight competitions the goal is
to make a model airplane that can be
launched by hand
or
towed into the air
on a rope like a kite
and then soar as long as possible within
a time limit without any remote or
automated controls to help keep it in
the air
aid karim knew all the tricks to making
a plane that can soar well
and in his los angeles garage he built a
uav technology demonstrator that was
truly innovative
karen called it the albatross
naming it after one of nature's greatest
soaring birds
his albatross offered phenomenal flight
endurance
up to 48 hours without refueling which
was far longer than any military uav
ever flown up to that time
based on his albatross demonstrator
karen got a contract from the defense
advanced research projects agency darpa
to develop a larger uav and a similar
configuration for the armed services
darpa named that little drone the amber
and in 1989 a senior darpa official
wrote in a magazine article that the
amber provided an order of magnitude
increase in the flight times recorded by
previous uavs
and that it had led the joint chiefs of
staff
to establish a new endurance category
and an unmanned aircraft master plan
ordered up by congress
yet largely for personal and
bureaucratic reasons that i detail in
the book
karen was unable to sell his drones to
the defense department and the company
he created to build them went bankrupt
in 1990
but thanks to some other unorthodox
thinkers
abe karem's ideas
his revolutionary ideas about uavs
didn't die when his company did
those ideas were rescued and karem and
his top engineers were hired
by a pair of brothers who had a genius
for business to match abe karim's genius
for aeronautics
oops i think i turned it off
there there
their names are neil and linden blue
they're the private owners of the san
diego area company that built the
predator general atomics
and while they're now in their late 70s
they're both still very active and
fascinating in their own right
in 1957 when the blue brothers were in
their early twenties and still students
at yale they made the cover of life
magazine
by flying a piper tri-pacer around latin
america during summer vacation
they decided to make that trip by the
way before they ever took their first
flying lesson
and that's because
that's because they weren't just
sightseeing
the blue brothers were born and bred
entrepreneurs
and in latin america they hoped to find
business opportunities they might pursue
after college
and as a result of that trip after they
graduated from yale
neil and london blue established a
banana and cacao plantation
on the east coast of nicaragua
in partnership with the ruling samosa
family
for the blues that venture only lasted a
couple of years but it was the first of
many that by the 1980s had made them
uncommonly wealthy
now as the name suggests general atomics
began as a nuclear energy company and it
still is one
but it got into the drone business after
the blue brothers bought it from chevron
in 1986
they had a number of reasons for
thinking uavs might be a good investment
but among their motives was a desire to
help the contra rebels in nicaragua
overthrow the leftist sandinistas
who in 1979 had overthrown the blues
former business partners the samosas
the blue brothers first attempted a
was a modified aluminum kit plane that
they were trying to equip
with a gps guided autopilot
neil blue's idea was that the contras or
an ally of the contras
i'm guessing the cia
could pack the plane's nose with
explosives and use it as a poor man's
cruise missile against the sandinistas
neal also thought such a weapon could
help deter or stop a soviet invasion of
western germany through the famous fulda
gap
neil blue wanted to call this kamikaze
drone the birdie because he said it was
going to be priced cheap cheap cheap
but i was surprised and not a little
amused to learn as i dug into this
history that the man neil blue hired to
run his company's unmanned aircraft
operations
a retired navy fighter pilot and rear
admiral named thomas j cassidy
gave this first general atomics uav what
would later become a famous name
predator
this unmanned kit plane had absolutely
nothing to do
with the predator we know today except
that name nothing in common
but tom cassidy who later proved as
adept at marketing and lobbying as he
was at flying fighter planes
tom cassidy liked that name predator and
he chose it for both of those general
atomics uavs
as i say in my book if necessity is the
mother of invention war is the mother of
necessity
and as with many technologies especially
aviation technologies war created the
necessities that gave birth to the
predator and the key innovations that
made it revolutionary
the war in bosnia and the difficulty of
finding serb artillery that was
bombarding sarajevo in 1993
led to the development of the second
drone called predator
which in fact was a derivative of a
smaller less capable uav that abe karem
had designed called the nat 750
in 1993 the cia bought two nat 750s from
general atomics to use in bosnia
in the photo at the bottom here the man
on to the right is abe karam
the man to the to his left is thomas
twetten who in 1993 was the cia's deputy
director of operations and went to
california to seal that deal for ci
director jim woolsey
who had known abe karum for years
at about the same time after
conversations with jim woolsey
under secretary of defense for
acquisition john deutch created a
program to to create to develop
an endurance unmanned aerial vehicle
similar to the nat 750 for the military
deutsch was in a hurry
he stipulated that this new uav had to
fly within six months of contract award
and to make that possible he adopted an
idea his deputy larry lynn had come up
with
a new rapid procurement method called
advanced concept technology
demonstrations known as actds
in january 1994 the defense department
gave general atomics the very first such
contract
abe karem and the team of engineers he
brought with him to general atomics
redesigned the net 750
and six months later the new predator
made its first flight
and now i'd like to elaborate on why i
said this book tells a story about the
air force and a story about the cia
one of the first things i did when i
began work on this book back in 2009
was to find officers who had flown the
predator or been involved in the program
in some other way
and interview them and the more air
force people i interviewed
the more i heard that i really needed to
talk to a civilian air force official
at the pentagon a former colonel with an
unforgettable nickname and as i soon
found out an unforgettable personality
snake clark knows more about the
predator than just about anybody people
said
snake i would say what's his real name i
don't know everybody calls him snake
well as former air force secretary whit
peter as well knows
snake's real name
is james g clark
and his air force job title these days
is director of intelligence surveillance
and reconnaissance innovations
but here's how i describe him in my book
in reality clark worked
what was that
that's on many of those early airplanes
well
at least when you put the laser
designator on
in reality this is what i say in the
book in reality clark worked for the
services two top leaders the four-star
chief of staff and the civilian
secretary of the air force
he was their favorite fixer an inside
operator who was canny about how to
bypass bureaucracy and who relished
getting things done as done as he liked
to put it quick and dirty
this was partly why clark encouraged
everyone to call him by his nickname
snake or if regulations required they
salute him colonel snake
he consciously cultivated the image of a
shrewd and slippery operator who might
be dangerous if stepped on
a reputation he found useful in
intimidating real or potential opponents
irreverent sassy and unafraid to step on
toes
clark was an acquired taste
he spoke in a preening pattern its
flavor was slightly acidic and
reminiscent of wc fields
and when someone got in his way he loved
what he playing what he called pentagon
poker
i'll see your three star and raise you a
four star
well i met snake clark at the air force
association's annual meeting in
september 2009 and visited with him at
his pentagon office soon afterward
i went back again a month later and back
again a month after that
and as i talked to snake clark i began
to understand that the predator was
unusual not only in how the pentagon had
bought it
but also in the way its capabilities
were improved and refined
initially as secretary whit peters
pointed out to me when i interviewed him
early on this project
the predator like the first personal
computers was a new technology that some
people found interesting but most
weren't sure how to benefit from
but over time a few interested
innovators came up with new software new
hardware new communications
architectures that transformed the
personal computer from a novelty into a
necessity and much the same thing
happened with the predator
at first this new endurance uav wasn't
important just interesting and only to a
few people at that
many weren't quite sure exactly what it
could do for them
the predator offered phenomenal flight
endurance
it could stay up as much as 40 hours
shooting live video in either color or
infrared
but it was also slow and flimsy and
vulnerable to icing
and while still photographs taken by
sr-71s
and u-2s and satellites were familiar
tools of military intelligence in the
1990s
early 1990s full motion video wasn't
when the predator made its debut in 1994
being flown by the army by the way
it was just a platform for a video
camera whose imagery was sent back to a
ground control station a nascar style
trailer at the time and went no farther
but by 2001 three years after the air
force took charge
it was the first weapon in history whose
operators could stalk and kill a single
individual on the other side of the
planet from a position of ambush and
total invulnerability
that transformation was largely
accomplished by a special air force unit
snake clark introduced me to
a unit i had never heard of before
even though i had written about the
military for three decades
officially it's the 645th aeronautical
systems group
headquartered at wright-patterson air
force base in dayton ohio
but since it was established in the
1950s
it's been called big safari
here's how i describe it in the book
created during the cold war to help the
air force the cia and other agencies
keep an eye on the soviet union and its
allies
big safari quickly evolved into a real
world echo though far less zany of cube
ranch the fictional british secret
service technology shop in the james
bond movies
big safari didn't rig attached cases to
spew tear gas or fit snazzy sports cars
with machine guns and ejection seats
but like double 07's cube branch big
safari was staffed with clever engineers
and technicians whose mission was to
devise and field off an exotic gear
quickly
big safari was just more specialized
beginning with its first assignment in
december 1952
installing the largest aerial camera
ever on a huge c-97 stratofrader cargo
plane a project code named pie faced
big safari's game was tricking out
special purpose aircraft
often with aerial reconnaissance devices
usually in a hurry and expressly for
special missions
big safari's director
when the air force took charge of the
predator
was bill grimes that's him on the right
with secretary peters and snake clark if
you can't see in the back
another retired colonel who stayed on
his in his job as a civilian bill grimes
and i reveal in the book how bill
grounds maneuvered on capitol hill
to make sure that big safari got to work
its wonders on the predator
another unorthodox thinker who played a
pivotal role in turning the predator
into a world changing technology is
someone whose photo i can't show you
a techno scientist of extraordinary
intellect and ability
who got interested in the predator when
it was still just a test technology and
flown by the army
snake clark calls him the man with two
brains
in the book by mutual agreement i call
him vanner
and i describe him in detail i have
described in detail some of the major
innovations banner came up with for the
predator
they include figuring out how to stream
predator video live to the pentagon and
other command centers from anywhere in
the world
mapping out a unique satellite setup so
that a big safari crew could fly a
predator over afghanistan in the fall of
2000 from a ground control station in
europe
and creating a new communications
architecture that made it possible in
2001
for crews in the united states to fly
armed predators over the other side of
the globe for the first time ever
that's a little hard to see but that's a
diagram
that's an air force diagram of how the
system works
as i explained in the book
making that link to a uav on the other
side of the earth isn't as simple as
subscribing to satellite tv
you can't just shoot a signal up to a
satellite in geostationary orbit and
bring it back down to a drone on the
other side of the planet
and you can't hopscotch the signal from
one satellite to another without the
distance the signal travels and the
processing required along the way
introducing enough latency enough delay
in the signal to make it difficult for a
crew to fly the drone remotely and
probably impossible to accurately aim
its missiles
but varner figured out how to rig a
system that holds the latency to
acceptable levels
and the air force is still using that
essential architecture he devised today
to fly what they now call remotely
piloted aircraft
that are a world away from bases here at
home
and that brings me to why this book also
tells a cia story
because vanner came up with split
operations as he called it
only so that an air force team in
germany could secretly fly an unarmed
predator over afghanistan
in the fall of 2000
to help the cia find osama bin laden
and that ad hoc unit of big safari
operators and air force intelligence
personnel
indeed found osama bin laden for the cia
less than a year later vanner then
invented what he dubbed remote split
operations
to give the cia the option of using an
armed predator to kill osama bin laden
without launching such a strike from
german soil
i explain in the book why moving the
ground control station out of germany
was deemed essential
and while the conventional wisdom has
been that the cia armed the predator and
that to quote one account the air force
decided that it couldn't be left behind
i found that the opposite was the case
the initiative to arm the predator was
in fact begun by air force general john
jumper in may 2000 not long after he
took over our combat command
and for reasons that had nothing to do
with the cia or osama bin laden
i explained his reasons and
circumstances in detail in the book
but here's what general jumper told me
in one of our interviews
all i wanted to do was to be able to
cure the problem that we had in kosovo
and that is the predator is sitting
there looking at the target
why can't you put something on there
that allows you to do something about it
instead of just looking at it
now it's true that the project to arm
the predator gained substantial momentum
after that air force team in germany
found osama bin laden in the fall of
2000.
but that acceleration was largely due to
the fact that by early 2000
richard clark the counterterrorism
director on the national security
council staff at the time
and a senior cia official named charlie
allen had come to the conclusion that
the united states needed to kill osama
bin laden
before he killed more americans as al
qaeda had done in the 1998 bombings of
our embassies in kenya and tanzania
and as they would do again by bombing
the us the destroyer uss cole
on october 12 2000
the air force conducted its first
hellfire missile test shot from a
predator on january 23
2001. and in the spring and summer that
year
top cia leaders rarely agreed to
consider
and i emphasize the words wearily and
consider
using this new armed uav to kill osama
bin laden
despite the perception today that the
cia is addicted to using drone strikes
to take out terrorists
there was great deal of unease at
langley before 9 11
at the idea of an espionage and analysis
service controlling a military weapon in
an operation that might lead to
headlines
such as cia uses drone to assassinate
islamic militant
even so big safari and a small cadre of
air force intelligence officers spent
much of the early part of 2001
preparing for just such a mission
and by the first week of september that
year
most of the elements were in place
uh this slide is difficult to see
especially from the back of fear but
these are google earth photos that show
the langley campus of the cia on
september 12 2001.
the inset shows a double wide mobile
home that served as the air force
predator team's command center
that small white rectangle next to it is
the first of two ground control stations
that were put there to fly the first
armed predators over afghanistan
they were painted white the ground
control stations to disguise them as
freight containers
my book describes in some detail some of
the early operations that were conducted
by the air force unit at this trailer
park as some called it and i described
them as they were described to me by
those who conducted and commanded them
that includes the escape on the first
night of the war in afghanistan of
taliban leader mohammed omar
who as you may already know almost
became the first high-value target ever
killed by an armed predator
my book also includes what i believe to
be the most accurate account to date
of the predator's role in the death of
al qaeda's third ranking leader and
military commander at the time of 9 11
osama bin laden's trusted friend
muhammad atta
and now
i'd like to explain
why i believe the predator gave birth to
today's drone revolution
drones have been around a long time and
they've been attempted in a wide variety
of configurations
by the 1990s
uav technology was improving and the
military was using or experimenting with
several types
but they were still in niche technology
given advances in the underlying
technologies
lightweight composite materials
smaller and more sophisticated cameras
digital communications gps i think it's
likely that in time uavs
would have become more than just a niche
technology in any event
but as i said earlier if necessity is
the mother of invention
war is the mother of necessity
and the wars of the late 20th century
produced the predator
and the predator made drones matter in
ways they never had before
big safari physically armed predator
3034 which now hangs in the national air
and space museum
starting in january 2001
and tested it that spring
starting with a static ground
test then firing missiles at targets
target tanks in the desert
and then firing them into a building the
cia had constructed to find out whether
hellfire missiles
which were designed to kill tanks
would kill osama bin laden who fired
into his residence in afghanistan
the contractor apparently misread the
specifications
and built a structure that bore little
resemblance to the mud and waddle houses
of afghanistan
so the testers nicknamed it taco bell
and hung this sign on
they were in a hurry at this point
so to help measure the hellfire's
lethality inside a building they had to
dispense with the usual mannequins
filled with ballistic gelatin
instead as you can see in this slide
they used plywood silhouettes and
watermelons to simulate people
but while big safari and people at lower
levels in the cia were getting prepared
to send the armed predator after osama
bin laden richard clark was having
trouble getting the leaders of the bush
administration to focus on the threat he
and others saw in al-qaeda
the bush national security council held
its first meeting to discuss sending the
armed predator after osama bin laden on
september 4th 2001
but while many of the preparations had
been made the ground control station was
already at the ci campus
neither the cia nor the military
wanted to take responsibility for
pulling the trigger
so they decided to wait
one week to the day later of course
everything changed
and the day after that three armed
predators were on their way to a base in
uzbekistan
where they could take off and land for
missions over afghanistan
predator 3034
bearing no markings at the time and
controlled from the trailer park at the
cia
launched the first hellfire predator
strike in afghanistan on the first night
of the war there october 7th 2001
a strike that i describe in some detail
three days later
president bush asked that an nsc meeting
why can't we fly more than one predator
at a time we ought to have 50 of these
things
and in december of that year bush gave a
speech to the corps of cadets at the
citadel in south carolina where he said
this
before the war the predator had skeptics
because it did not fit the old ways
now it is clear the military does not
have enough unmanned vehicles
now
as i said earlier given the rapid
advances in component technologies it's
fairly certain that at some point drones
would have evolved into more than just a
niche technology anyway
but if the definition of a technological
revolution is the same as the definition
of a scientific revolution
a breakthrough moment that disrupts
accepted thinking and offers
unanticipated ideas
it seems to me that arming the predator
and rigging it for global remote control
was just such a moment and now what
followed was indeed a technological
revolution
of course all i can offer is
circumstantial evidence
but beyond president bush's statement at
the citadel
and the fact that the cia has come to
rely heavily on a weapon they were once
reluctant to use there's this
as 2001 began the entire u.s military
owned a total of just 82 unmanned aerial
vehicles of three types
the predator still unarmed at that point
and two small reconnaissance drones the
navy marine corps pioneer and the army's
hunter
a pentagon study issued in april 2001
five months before 9 11
estimated that by 2010
the armed services might
have as many as 290 uavs in all but
still have only three types
when 2010 in fact arrived the military
owned nearly 8 000 uavs of 14 different
types and i think the number today is
more like ten thousand
today the air force is annually training
more remotely piloted aircraft operators
than regular pilots
the army is flying its own predator
derivative
the navy and air force are developing
fighter-sized unmanned combat aerial
vehicles
as many as 80 nations are building their
own military uavs
and civilian use of drones has already
outstripped the federal aviation
administration's ability to regulate it
in short
i think air and space smithsonian
magazine got it right
the predator changed the world
because it disrupted accepted thinking
and offered unanticipated ideas and what
followed was a drone revolution that is
still unfolding
thank you for listening and again i
thank the dhl and my great friend
wolfgang podzick for inviting me to talk
here at the army navy club
it's been an honor and in whatever time
we have remaining i'll do my best to
answer your questions
[Applause]
richard thank you that was great and i'm
sure there are quite a few questions if
i may
let me start with with two
uh to add uh two additional aspects to
this debate
there are legal
implications the implications
from an ethical point of view
moral point of view is this all fair to
go after people who may not have
committed any crime
one just anticipates that they will
how do you look at all this and and what
about the
authorization of drone strikes
who who can do this is this satisfactory
today etc etc second you just mentioned
80 some countries developed drones
10 years down the road boarding a united
delta usf flight is that safe
well
uh there's a there's a lot there
um i
uh i think that the uh your first
question uh there there's a fairness
question that gets raised a lot about
armed drones
uh and and the one question is
um
is it fair
for
our
military personnel
to
sit in perfect safety
and kill people on the other side of the
world and
and my
feeling about that is that if you accept
the morality of war to start with
commanders have
two primary obligations the first is to
win
and the second is to protect their
people as best they
can i think that fairness
is a concept that is
very vital to sports
but but not doesn't really have a role
in war
uh i mean i generals often will say
we're not interested in fair fight
and so i see nothing at all uh i i just
think it's a
it's a red herring to say that there's
something unfair about using this weapon
in military operations it's uh
in many ways it's a great boon to the
military
now
the
the whole area of drone strikes targeted
killings
raises a different set of issues
as i think you know the military
operates under title 10.
the intelligence agencies operate under
title 50 and presidential findings and
executive orders
and
i think one for me as a citizen
one question i have is whether we don't
need better checks and balances on the
executive branch
and more information about how people
are put on the target list
what the standards of evidence are
and and i would be personally more
comfortable if we had
maybe the kind of situation we have with
the fisa court for foreign intelligence
surveillance act a wiretap
i believe a judge has to approve a
warrant
and at least someone in judiciary has to
review the evidence now i have lawyers
here who will correct me on my details
but
but the general principle i think is
that i would like the executive branch
to have some
more check and balance on it than they
have
they they inform certain members of
congress
i don't actually know whether they
inform them before or after the targeted
killing has taken place but it's my
understanding that those members of
congress are not free
to do anything with the information
so um i i think that's and and let's say
also you know the question of targeted
killings is not just a question of using
drones
i mean the the principle is uh when the
obama administration issued a public
memo
uh on the legal justification for the
killing of
awlaki
much of it was redacted
but the but the justification was
essentially that
that the government has
i think it's called the public authority
right to kill people in certain
circumstances so anyway i think that's a
whole a tangled area and and it's and
that memo didn't use the word drone it
only talked about
uh i don't remember the exact phrase but
it talked about targeted killings and
the point is
uh you don't have to use a drone to
target someone and kill then you can do
it with a knife too so we have to decide
as a society whether this is what we
want to be
doing
charlie
charlie stevenson seis
rick you've written about other
aircraft the v22 osprey written now
about the predator
what lessons would you offer for how the
u.s government can do a better job
dealing with revolutionary technologies
i i assume you mean in the acquisition
of them and and
why does it take us why do we have
situations like we have now with the
f-35
or the projects that have been going on
for years and years and years and why
can't we get there
you know i thought about that a lot and
and i wish i had
some good easy answers i think i would
be a genius if i did have because a lot
of smart people work on this
you being among work on these questions
all the time the interesting thing to me
about the difference between the osprey
and the predator and the acquisition
is that with the osprey you started out
the v22 osprey tilt rotor that takes off
like a helicopter and flies like an
airplane
in shorthand i i call it the ugly
duckling that turned into a swan because
it had a very troubled development
process but now it's doing wonderful
things
for the marine corps and the air force
but it took
25 years and 22 billion dollars
and 30 lives lost before the osprey
became
uh the great aircraft that it is today
um
it started out as a project a joint
project in which for all four services
were to be involved and there were ten
different missions it was supposed to do
and uh list of requirements that went on
and on and on
uh that the the people designing it and
building it had to meet
with the predator
it was almost like that build it and
they will come
you know it was a very there was
actually a very simple list of uh
requirements only three or four in john
deutsch's memo in 1993
and
i think that that that obviously
simplifies the process
a great deal and i and i think that
uh
writing the requirements for military
equipment
is where the system gets bogged down a
lot because
there's a temptation
to
you know ask for
the impossible and i think that defense
contractors have a great motive to say
oh yeah we can do that easy cheap
and it turns out not to be that way
so i think i think one of the areas that
should be focused on is that the whole
process of writing requirements and and
thinking about whether
uh you know big safari which developed
uh the predator in many ways
uh
one of their many mottos is look for the
80 solution
and that's not a bad motto
all right
building weapons anyway
wolfgang schaefer of georgia
international thanks for a great
presentation my question is give them
this extensive hacking we experience
every day you know target home depot
the chinese are hacking all of our
computers here the nsa is not bad either
how can we make sure and be sure
that these predators are not going to be
controlled by hacker
and then turn against another target
including ourselves
well it's a question that's on a lot of
people's minds
um i would be
uh lying if i said that i know the
technical answer because i am really not
not an engineer
i'm a storyteller
and i have told the story by
interviewing people who who are experts
uh i'm told however
uh by uh people who are expert on this
that at this point the military has
encrypted
signals for all of the
major air major uavs the large ones
and that there is really no danger
little to no danger of anyone being able
to hijack them or control them
or even or even see the data that
they're transmitting
now someone else told me that
well they still can be jammed their
signals can be jammed
um
but
as i say that's uh
that's certainly a risk but i think it's
one the military has thought about
yes sir
yes uh my name is gene delgado i'd like
to direct you a little bit back to uh
wolfgang's question as we all know
technology that we thought was closely
held
soon finds its way getting around the
world
various people can get hold of the same
technology
i'm wondering how detectable is
the predator to the radar which is used
to follow commercial flights and what is
the possibility that this wolfgang is
positive that if we could reach a point
in time where someone who is an
adversary of ours could actually use
that same technology against a civilian
aircraft
[Music]
the
there are countries out there trying the
chinese have a sort of predator knockoff
called the pterodactyl
and if you've seen a photograph of it it
looks very similar
i think that the uh
i think that the the the aircraft
technology is is not the secret
uh
lots of countries may be able to
duplicate aircraft like that
uh but the software
and the communications architecture
are very special
and i think that
very few countries would be able to
duplicate that now
also the predator while
fairly hard to detect i tell the story
in the book of how
when
captain scott swanson was piloting the
predator over afghanistan in the fall to
september 2000 looking for osama bin
laden
the
taliban scrambled to mig
that came up and and swanson and the
other
members of the crew in the ground
control station at ramstein air base
were
bobbing and weaving and and uh
maneuvering the aircraft to make it as
small as possible in the mig
a mig jet fighter and and
and that jet fighter pilot failed to see
the predator and flew right by it
because you know it flies it cruises at
roughly let's say 82 miles an hour
um
and and if it's painted air superiority
gray as
as it was when they sent it into action
over afghanistan it's pretty hard to see
but
if you do detect it it's quite easy to
shoot down
in fact one the air force general told
me that the best way to shoot down a
predator is to fly next to it in a
helicopter with a 12-gauge shotgun
so
so i think
other countries may be able to duplicate
aspects of the technology aircraft like
this
i don't think that they're going to be
successful in getting over our borders
we have the best air defenses i assume i
hope in the world
i can ask
secretary peters here
um
uh but anyway we have substantial air
defenses and uh and i don't think that
we have to worry about um
people flying those kinds of drones over
our territory uh especially since the
communications architecture is such you
know that
as that diagram shows the signal has to
go by fiber optic cable from here
under the atlantic ocean
to europe where it joins the satellite
earth terminal and goes up to the
predator and i don't know
it's a i think a pretty expensive
proposition and
i don't think many countries can do that
so
i think that the greater threat actually
to to us in america from unmanned
aircraft is from a small
unmanned aircraft
even down to the size of the parcel
copter
if someone some nefarious group wanted
to take one and put some sort of
explosives on it
but that would just be a terror weapon
you know that wouldn't be
a weapon of any military significance
i rambled a bit but i hope i answered
your question
yes ma'am
thank you esther uh george washington
university may i follow up on that last
point and look a little bit farther out
into the future again on the civilian
uses of the technology right could you
comment on what you might expect of the
regulatory framework to look like will
the national civil aviation organization
be involved how is that going to develop
what that what would that look like and
how will that change the environment in
which all of these uh aircraft operate
thank you well i think there's a there's
a gentleman at the federal aviation
administration named jim williams who
would love it if i could
give him the answer to that question
because uh that's something that the faa
is struggling with and as i'm sure you
know
um you know the the one of the big
issues one of the big problems one of
the different one of the technical
hurdles
uh for people in the uh unmanned
aircraft industry to get over for
civilian use is safety
i mean for a
piloted aircraft have to be able to see
and avoid other aircraft
so there are lots of companies the the
defense department
uh are working on technologies
uh to
provide the a uav
an unmanned aircraft the ability to
sense and avoid other aircraft or detect
and avoid other aircraft
and and i think it's a real question as
to how heavy and how expensive that
technology has to be
and without it i think there are
definite limits to
uh what you're going to be able to do
with this technology
because you can't just flood the skies
with with
aircraft that may run into
uh other aircraft or
fall from the sky and hurt people or
cause damage to buildings or whatever so
safety is is a major concern and a major
hurdle and uh
we're not there yet you know i'm kind of
i
having
looked at this story and
uh in the book tell the story of how
variner came up with this
uh remote split operations
uh uh
to solve a major problem that arose in
this planned
operation
[Music]
i think i'm i'm very hesitant to try to
predict the future because i don't think
a month before he did that anyone would
have predicted that you could control
a uav on the other side of the globe
from the united states in fact
all the all the other experts were
saying this can't be done we're going to
shut down the operation
so um
but i am reminded also of the
fact that
you know when i wrote the book about the
osprey i wrote about the 1930s that the
dream that that inspired the tilt rotary
aircraft to dream of creating an
aircraft that could do everything a bird
could do
and the dream of flying cars
well we're still waiting for flying cars
and i don't know how air traffic control
would work
if uh if all of us had the ability to
suddenly decide well i'm sick of this
traffic jam i'm going to fly over to the
grocery store you know i just
there's some problems that may be in the
end insoluble
so
i hope that helps
yes sir
thank you i'm rafi danziger an advisor
to aipac
and in a way this is the most specific
follow-up on a previous question with
regard to the ability of duplicating the
drones
as you know a drone crashed in iran
and the iranians are claiming they'll be
able that were able to reverse engineer
it and now they have their own drones
which are the same as the ones that has
crashed to the best of your knowledge
were the iranians able to duplicate not
just the frame but also the uh the
electronics thank you
you're asking me whether they were able
to
well i i don't know but i doubt it
um
you know i think that
it was interesting to me when they when
they held their news conference and they
showed this is the rq 170 sentinel
uh which previously had sort of been
known to reporters as the beast of
kandahar because
they would just get glimpses of it from
time to time
a sort of batwing-shaped
drone but when that was put on display
in iran one of the notable things about
it was that they didn't show you the
landing gear
and uh they had a flag or something
draped across the front
um and and i have talked to people who
know more about these things than i who
who say that you know that suggests to
them that that aircraft came in for a
pretty hard landing
and
it's unlikely that it was intact
when they found it
it looked like a strange
beast uh actually when they showed it at
their news conference
uh but but i don't know the answer to
that question i mean that was a that's a
classified uh it was a classified
aircraft
uh before the iranians uh got it and but
uh i've also been told and i think it
makes more sense to me than anything
else that wasn't a case of the iranians
taking it over and bringing it in as
they said either i think that it lost
link
it
you know lost the signal
and
went and it went down and probably had a
hard landing
i have answered every question any
additional comment and question
feel free to
chime in
there's one more please richard douglas
um
rick you know you've written your
previous book about the v22 which i
think is more of a characteristic
program about the aerospace and defense
industry it's more incremental this
really is as you say a revolution it's a
tremendous story and the v22 great story
too but more incremental there are very
few opportunities to observe a
revolution uh as it happens in the
aerospace or defense industry do you see
anything else on the in the future on
the horizon that could
approximate something of this magnitude
in aerospace and defense in terms of
emerging technologies or even
requirements
wow i can count on you richard to pose
the unanswerable question
i think that if i knew the answer to
that i wouldn't tell you because i'd be
working on a book about it
that's my that's my answer
on that note richard thank you very much
[Applause]
thank you very much and thank you all
for being here
for those who have not received the book
with his signature please i think
there's some copies left thank you for
joining us see you soon i hope
if you missed any of this discussion a
reminder that you can watch 48 hours of
book tv starting saturday mornings at 8
eastern authors discussions and the
history of books all on book tv here on
c-span 2.
and coming up tonight here